[Applause]
he's got the backing of the Scottish
Parliament that's the easy part but as
Hamza Yusuf settles in as Scotland's
first Minister selling his vision for
the nation may be tougher I've always
believed that leadership is about
running towards and embracing challenges
rather than shying away from them we
might not be able to achieve everything
we want all of the time and all at once
but every day in office is an
opportunity to make things a bit better
than they were yesterday
just down the road from Parliament
Giancarlo De Soto runs a fudge making
business with his brother the firm's
been in the family for three generations
John Carlo would rather Scotland stay in
the family known as the United Kingdom
and he wants the Scottish government to
focus on countering the harm done by
brexit are they trying to make it easier
for you know for people even just to
come over I think to make it easier for
businesses
um I think it should be like less
sanctions on you know things like trying
to import goods and stuff like that I
think you know businesses I think really
suffer from these things
Youssef said he's going to concentrate
on things like improving child care and
public health services this couple are
expecting their third child as
supporters of the Scottish national
party they agree Independents can wait
you know what the Western Star saying
that all the SMP care about as
Independence and their you know they're
letting other things slide so I think
maybe if we get other things in place
first then we can build an end for
Independence step away from picturesque
parts of the capital like this and
you'll get an idea of the challenges
facing Hamza Yusuf for example a recent
survey showed four percent of Scottish
households use the food bank in the year
to March 2022 that's more than anywhere
else in Britain apart from northern
England
not surprising then that the first
Minister has said the cost of living
crisis is his top priority but even here
in working class Leaf some people say
independence should not be relegated to
the bottom of the pile uh jump in the
class chapter the class
yes Nicholas sturgeon couldn't do it and
I've never done business again is that
England it stops US Youssef says he'll
need to convince many more people
Independence is a good idea some may be
Beyond convincing
I'm not just professional Liars of
course nobody's predicting Scotland will
break away anytime soon but the
government hopes improving the economy
could prepare the ground for another go
at a referendum Nadine barber Al Jazeera
Edinburgh